Rishi sunak is Britain's third prime
minister in a space of just two months
and he inherited daunting set of
problems in the wake of the brief and
chaotic tenure of his predecessor Liz
truss some mistakes were made
sunak's message I'm here to fix those
problems
and that work begins immediately
I will place economic stability and
confidence
at the heart of this government's agenda
this will mean difficult decisions to
come
Richie sunac warned of the profound
economic challenges that the UK now
faces now as he sweeps into Downing
Street for the first time as prime
minister it's time to set out his agenda
addressing the question about his
mandate to govern after so many changes
of prime minister without an election he
put the election-winning 2019 Manifesto
at the center of his program and in a
perceived swipe at both Boris Johnson
and Liz truss sunak admitted I have work
to do to restore Trust
this government
will have integrity
professionalism
and accountability at every level
Trust
is earned and I will earn yours
on the same spot just 90 minutes earlier
Downing Street had seen the departing
speech of Liz truss the shortest serving
prime minister in British history after
just 50 days in charge there was little
for her to claim credit for so a short
speech ended in a simple platitude I
believe in in the British people and I
know that brighter days lie ahead thank
you
sunax elevations of prime minister has
received congratulations from around the
world the U.S President Joe Biden
described the first British Asian prime
minister as groundbreaking
pretty astounding a groundbreaking
Milestone and it matters it matters and
from the European commission Chief
Ursula Von delayan we count on a strong
relationship with the UK to defend our
common values but in Russia the Kremlin
said it saw no grounds for hope that
there'll be any positive changes for
soon act though the task of assembling
his government is the immediate priority
stability and confidence to replace
turbulence and division Paul Brennan Al
Jazeera Downing Street